level one level 2 and level 3
and we need to get over ourselves and our own egos
it is a spectrum
level 3 tends to be minimally or complete inability to speak
supports and services
there are some days where I can handle change a lot better than others etc etc
like I have good days and bad days
we are all equally artistic♾️
so within those levels you are going to fluctuate
is to be able to have language to express the spectrum
and the reason that the support levels are so important is
types of individuals who need different levels of support
it is possible for support levels to change
but that happens slowly over time and usually requires read diagnosis
talking about support needs isn't harmful
is that the reality is that some artistic♾️ people need more support than others
level 3 is the highest amount of support that can be given to an artistic♾️ person
and level 3 means that you need high the highest amount of support
level one means that you need some support
we need to remember
level 3 isn't just me
and the next day need 24 7 care because I'm unable to feed myself
and we need language to be able to describe those differences
however it doesn't fluctuate to the degree
level 3 is 24 7 care
which is nonsense by the way
so that all artistic♾️ people can get the supports and services that we need
it's necessary so we can actually get support
I'm not going to one day be level one support
are level one support need artistics♾️
in this person
and if we take away this language
that kind of fluctuation doesn't happen
and it tends to be because
but it's a spectrum that does contain many different
what we are saying is
on a bad day
the only people that I've heard express issues about the level system
a lot of us have decided that we feel invalidated by the idea of support levels
then we take away our means of describing what individuals need
that does not happen
if we're no longer able to say hey
this person hat needs higher amount of support on a continual basis
level 3 often means no functional communication
level 2 means that you need more support
for whatever reason
I posted a video recently talking about this
that I'm fluctuating on a daily basis between levels
nobody saying that one person is more artistic♾️ than another
it's not from high to low
dress myself and I keep running into the street and nearly being hit by a car
in terms of access
hi I think this is a common misunderstanding
so let's address it
yes people support needs can fluctuate day to day
but people's level of support does not fluctuate
so for example there are different diagnostic levels of support